our financial conflict of interest rules
hurting the practice of medicine dr
thomas dossel is the american cancer
society professor of medicine at harvard
medical school dr stossel spoke at
recent weekend in saint petersburg
florida to deliver a contrarian take on
a subject that has drawn national media
attention the excessive regulation of
financial arrangements between
physicians and the pharmaceutical
industry i'm talking about a sliver of
the huge healthcare issue
that i hope i can convince you is
important and is worth doing something
about
so it
is
the financial conflict of interest
mainly
now i put it in quotes because it's
a sort of meaningless term it's a code
word for any transfer of value from a
medical products company device company
drug company to a physician
and it presupposes
potential or actual
toxicity of that transfer of value and
so these transfers must be disclosed
managed or eliminated
now what i
plan to do is just tell you a few things
about me my background as to how i got
to this
and then i will describe what the mania
is and it is a mania because it has no
substance although it has substantive
effects i'll tell you what's wrong with
it and then i hope i can kick off a
discussion as to what should we do about
it
now
you've heard my background but most of
what i've done in my life is research
and i do research on a sort of arcane
topic which is how your cells crawl did
you know that your cells crawl
so here's your pearl for the day each
one of you makes a hundred billion white
blood cells
and they get a free ride in the blood
for a little while but their real job is
to come out of the bloodstream into
every part of your body and find eat and
kill germs that's why you're walking and
talking because they do that
and uh it each one crawls about an
eighth of an inch and a hundred billion
times an eighth of an inch is over twice
around the earth every day in each one
of us and we don't even know it now
what's cool about cell white blood cell
crawling is you can see it that's a
white blood cell the big thing in the
middle the dark things are red blood
cells and that little white black dot is
a germ that it's chasing it's sort of
like a good version of the irs going
after the tea party
and i've spent 40 years
doing research on what's under the hood
as to how this process works this
machine works cool huh
now the good news is i've been very
successful with that i've spent a lot of
your tax money on to do this research
and i've won all kinds of prizes and
awards and uh gotten into elite clubs
but the bad news is no one has lived one
second longer or better because of this
research
now random events can sometimes bail you
out in the late 1980s
i was asked to join the scientific
advisory board of one of the pioneering
biotech companies biogen
and the reason these people are in the
silly sort of configuration is i made
some smart remark and then they all put
those beanies on
uh but these folks are some pretty uh
cool dudes they're nobel prize winners
and other luminaries
um and the experience that biogen sort
of shocked me out of my socialist youth
i realized that uh and how difficult it
is to convert research into into
practical ends and it started me on the
path of trying to do that
now i want to call your attention to the
the gentleman in the circle his name is
ken murray
he was a scottish
biologist who biogen paid to in his
laboratory do some work that led to a
vaccine for the disease the liver
disease hepatitis b
and biogen took it forward and that made
biogen for the first time a profitable
company
and
the the as a result
murray who had stock and stock options
in the company became extremely wealthy
but
hepatitis b causes liver cancer it's the
major cause of liver cancer in the world
and it will be eradicated thanks to his
work so the value for humanity's
incalculable and the fact that he got
rich is not shouldn't be an issue
but remember that story as we go forward
because i will uh come back to it now
timing is everything and be as as i was
learning about the market at biogen the
conflict of interest mania emerged and
i've been in medicine almost 50 years
and as you can see so for the first half
of my career no one talked about
conflict of interest
but uh it then just came out abruptly in
all these books and articles and uh it's
astonishing how they had the legs that
it has and the amount of material that
this gets now who's putting this stuff
out well i come in two flavors i call
them instigators and enablers now some
of the instigators are committed
believers but most of them are
opportunists and so the the academics
have discovered they can make a living
declaring that conflict of interest is a
national emergency of course the media
loves corruption whether it exists or
not and politicians charles grassley has
been a major perpetrator of this and
then the arch instigators are the
lawyers we'll be saying more about that
now it's the enablers or the people who
run the medical profession at the top
who are who make the rules
and what they really care about is not
having their new york times beat them up
or charles grassley come after them and
so they have just rolled over and
accepted the tenets of this mania
now what does the mania say
fundamentally what it says is that
industry isn't worth the value for money
all it does is market it markets
products
that
are no better
are just more expensive
and less safe than what's already out
there
and then finally you've read about these
enormous eye-popping fines that get
inflicted on these on the industry and
this is the smoking gun that industry is
fundamentally criminal
so they've been very successful as a
result of these allegations
in promoting rules
and so we have massive confession
everything has to be disclosed and then
that information is used to restrict the
kind of rewards that i told you about
that ken murray got who unfortunately
died last year but
he could not because he cannot at my
medical school have sponsored research
from a company if you have equity in
that company and that's ridiculous
arguably we wouldn't have a hepatitis b
vaccine if
those rules had been in effect when he
did that work
and then the real whipping boy of the
conflict of interest mania is marketing
it's that marketing that doctors are
incapable of sorting out truth from
fiction and so there should be complete
apartheid between the sales forces of
industry and the medical profession
now
obamacare of course is front and center
in your discussions but how many of you
are familiar with the sunshine act
that's a problem what the sunshine act
is is that every transfer of value of
ten dollars or more must be disclosed to
the federal government
and it has in effect right now it will
appear on public websites
the ten dollar figure says a lot it says
how mean-spirited the mania is the idea
that ten dollars is enough to cause
corruption
now what's wrong with this
well the main thing is they get it
totally wrong about value now in that 50
years that i've been in medicine it has
gotten incomparably better than when i
started out and the statistics are there
so the number one cause of death
is cardiovascular disease as you can see
it has fallen by 60 percent
the death rate of course remains one per
person
so you don't die of the number one cause
now you are at risk for number two
that's cancer but as you can see cancer
mortality remained flat and is at an
all-time low
some of you may remember when the hiv
aids epidemic came out and there were
apocalyptical predictions it would
bankrupt the health care system and
there was a death rate went up
and then went down and it went away and
people now live with aids
all of this progress is because of the
tools that physicians now have and those
tools come from industry and from
industry collaborating with physicians
it's inconceivable that if all industry
did was market
ineffective unsafe expensive products
that we could have this
amazing product progress
but that's what they claim
now you all know moore's law
moore's law that chips get exponentially
more powerful and exponentially cheaper
well in medical product development it's
the opposite so i call it e-rome's law
over my lifetime it has become a hundred
times more expensive to get a drug
approved by the fda and you see the
dismal statistic that one in eight
thousand drug candidates actually makes
it to approval and you see how long it
takes and how expensive it is why is
that well it's not because as the
conflict of interest mania says because
industries bad intentions it's because
of
failure a huge failure rate now you've
made me familiar that product of the
approvals require going through these
phases that have different aspects of
what uh the research that goes on to
determine the safety and efficacy of a
product but what you the most important
point is that around half of these
attempts fail at each step
of the process and that's why it takes
so long and it's so expensive now why is
the failure rate so high it's because
biology is a [ __ ]
it's not intuitively obvious that that
should be so i mean we can build
airplanes that fly themselves and never
crash unless they're flown by crazy
malaysians but
it's the reason for that is because we
designed them we designed them to be
predictable and that predictability is
what allows for that amazing technical
uh competence that we have but in
medicine biology it's not like that we
evolved and the success of our evolution
our survival
depends on our unpredictability because
that like that germ that that white
blood cell was chasing is very good at
keying in to our moving parts and if all
our moving parts were predictable we'd
have been wiped out eons ago
so that incredible unpredictability is
the basic
explanation uh for this difficulty and
explains why the companies have to be
profitable they have to be able to take
as many shots on goal as they can
because they're going to have all these
failures so the profitability is
essential and to be profitable they have
to be able to sell
now the
mantra that the conflict of interest
mania sells that this marketing is
dishonest devious and doctors can't deal
with it it's just false because bias
they always talk about bias bias can be
evidence-based i'm biased towards disc
brakes and seat belts and not smoking
it's based on evidence the marketing
apparatus can only tell doctors what the
fda has approved and that's very
rigorous evidence
there are enough practices however now
that have restricted marketing personnel
from their practices that an economist
at temple university did a huge study
and showed that in the pr in the
practices that restricted the drug reps
they were slower to adopt a new product
but more importantly they were slower to
stop prescribing a product that had been
shown to have side effects
one of the reasons i'm so passionate
about this is because i've had to work
my butt off to accomplish all those
things that
peter talked about
they just make things up i've never been
allowed to just make things up i've
always had to get evidence and it's
unconscionable that they're allowed to
get away with it i mean this is just not
true there's no fda that tells mount
sinai what it can say about prostate
surgery and you see if you flew down
here you look at the airplane ads it's
just full of this kind of puff
every major pharmaceutical and device
company has paid these enormous fines
for health care fraud and if you read
the fine print it's specific drugs that
which were supposedly marketed off label
or bribes and kickbacks
is this true does this make them felons
well the answer is no it's a creative
legal strategy
now
once a product is approved it gets a
label the label says what
the company can say about that product
once it's approved for anything though a
doctor can prescribe it for anything
else and in fact off-label prescribing
is very common especially in cancer
treatment in children where no trials
have been done in fact it would be
malpractice
not to prescribe some many medications
off label
and at least until recently being paid
to consult for a device company was
perfectly legal
off-label promotion however since the
key fobber harris amendments to the fda
in the 60s is illegal
and of course kickbacks are illegal
so in the for most of history the fda
would keep an eye on companies and if
they thought there was
off-label promotion they tell them to
stop and if they didn't stop they'd get
a prosecutor to to go after them but
about a decade ago a
creative strategy
evolved that was based on false claims
now false claims date back to the civil
war
which it was used to punish contractors
who bill the government for services
they didn't do
false claims have some unique features
one is that if you get a conviction
the damages are three times so that's
why the numbers are so great you wait
long enough for the company to sell
enough product and you got a huge number
second it's very generous with
whistleblowers then there's a third
component which i'll come to in a second
now in order to get the conviction the
prosecutor after because it's not the
company that's making the false claim
it's not the company that's doing the
prescribing the doctors doing the
prescribing so the prosecutor has to
prove
that the company's marketing made the
doctor prescribe off label now that's
ridiculous there's no way you could
prove that in court
but it never goes to court it doesn't go
to court
because the companies settle and as a
result there's never judicial review now
why do they settle it's because of that
third difference between false claims
and other kinds of of uh prosecutions
there is a draconian penalty called
debarment
debarment means the company cannot sell
any of its products to the federal
government no medicare no medicaid no
s-chip that's capital punishment there's
no way a company can risk that and the
prosecutors pile up
so many indictments that as improbable
as it is if only one
gets the to be a conviction
d bar
now another piece of evidence that this
is bogus is that individuals who don't
care about debarment they care about
their reputation when they fight it in
court they win this is arguably the most
damaging aspect of the conflict of
interest mania
and
it's probably to a large extent
responsible for the principal costs so
payments from device companies to
surgeons have gone down by 75 percent in
the last five years
corporate subsidy for medical education
has gone down by 50 in the same time and
the number of medical education events
has dropped by the same amount that's
problematic especially in rural areas
where we want doctors to keep up and uh
they're they no longer uh have access to
this education and then finally that
what
sunshine act that intuitively well
what's wrong with transparency well
nobody ever asks what does it cost the
the act is 300 pages of legal gibberish
and a huge number of lawyers compliance
bureaucrats are going to have to tell
the companies how to comply with it and
it's going to cost billions that would
be better put into research and
development
now why if there's nothing there and
it's costly does it go from strength to
strength
i think it's because we've been wimps
especially the industry's been wimps so
we do good things we do good things oh
no it's it's still
flat earth versus round earth is not a
difference of opinion it's a matter of
right and wrong and the companies should
say
no we're not corrupt you're corrupt
because you're intellectually dishonest
but they haven't done that
so what should we do
well i've
i sort of came out of the closet with
this about 10 years ago and i've
probably
given
150 talks panels interviews written 50
op-ed articles and
articles on on this topic it's gone from
bad to worse
i wish we could mobilize industry i wish
we could get patients to understand that
this is this is uh not going to help
them and it's going to slow innovation
um but
i'm a bit discouraged at this point
so i need
your help and your ideas
so every time i give a talk to a
scientific audience i have to show a
slide like this
that's
statutory at professional societies and
education events
uh where the purpose is so you can see
that i lie cheat and steal and you can't
trust anything that i have to say
i have gotten a small grant from the
searle freedom trust which i think
supports you folks
to continue this work
they're concerned that i've had no
success in changing policy and uh so i
really hope that in the course of the
discussion today and over the rest of
the weekend that you can give me some
ideas and uh maybe or tell me to give it
up and stop tilting the windmill and go
to my day job in any case thank you for
your attention i appreciate